yeah I listen to all my books through
audio is that not reading then it's not
you didn't read it now you heard I know
I'm just saying though it is
word-for-word the book yeah so what's
the difference you heard a book I know
but I know but like because when people
go have you read a book maybe yeah I
read power of now oh that's my favorite
book I love that book
I love the hook and I believe it a
hundred but I didn't do it I can't do it
either
I don't apply it I don't apply that
drives me crazy trying yeah cuz I'm
every time I drift off into sick a
memory you're not supposed to write
you're supposed to be you gently bring
yourself back right into things the
Apple that you're holding the grain of
rice in your mouth everything has to be
present and it almost threw me into like
an anxiety attack every day because I
kept trying to practice it too hard yeah
this stuff I mean it can really throw
you into a life crisis all of its about
like getting rid of your ego which is
your brain is fighting to keep it and
but your brain has to decide to let it
go it's the old arsonist is the chief of
police yeah trying to find the arsonist
is there a way to make your ego an ally
in some portions of your life for
instance like for Bobby let's say for
instance he's an ambitious guy and a
part of his ego just keeps him driven
and keeps him you know wanting more yeah
yeah but is there a way to make it so
that ego is not always the total enemy
well I think you know realize the only
thing you can really try to do is watch
it and watch okay I tend to have these
thoughts but the thing is is this is
that the greater question is why in my
in my adult life
do I need to listen to self-help books
right like I read that I've done The
Four Agreements I've done every Deepak
Chopra I've done every skip and skip
like I don't fine but I have I have the
quote
quantum physics music yeah like what you
know how you know I've told this before
dude do you know why I stopped following
that guy well because um well I told you
the whole reason why I even got in depth
Deepak Chopra ever tell you about that I
remember so um this is beef right the
couple of months before I got MADtv
obviously I was a doorman at the store
and no money and had no future that's
how you feel as an open mind you know
how well you're a young comic you look
around you see somebody like making it
yeah because you're around it and as a
young company go how do you get there it
seems impossible right you're just
everyday can I see your ID can I say hey
can you not heckle during the show
you're a doorman at a club and then you
see other guys come in their fancy cars
and they have a hot chick and they go
yeah we make it I make 80,000 a week on
this stone so show it to mystery it's
not like it's a lawyer right you get
these steps you pass the bar none you go
you just show up and so when I used to
get stressed out I used to get boils
that's hot yeah I used to get them in my
armpit and I'm on the top of my head all
right and my mom gets him when we talked
about it with my mom she got these
gigantic boils and I know how to Lance
them organically bragger I'm being cocky
yes yeah yeah so I was getting so
desperate and so depressed that a boil
appeared on my cheek right and that's
when I know things aren't going well
when they're boils on my cheek so ill
alarm boil alone so I was at the Comedy
Store and I was walking up the steps you
know Jason Killearn no he's a comic he's
a teacher though and he oh he always
gets the late spots like midnight 1:00
in the morning but he does get spots in
coolers like Haley I go yeah and he just
out of nowhere he goes Chopra like a
what Deepak shop or you know I don't
know is he a calm
he said no using the Rolling Stone
magazine and there's an article about
him you should read it I guess he just
kind of knew that I was just like going
through something yeah so when we were
after my chef went to 7-Eleven and I
found it bought it I read about him and
I'm like yeah I don't can't even afford
his books I don't know money right the
next weekend
on a Friday I do La Jolla I'm not
headlining I'm like OMG or featuring or
something and I'm on stage because I'm
from there I'm on stage and there's this
girl in the front row her name is Katie
and I used to wait tables in La Jolla
cuz he still would live there um
Brockton Villa and she was somebody
worked with in my early 20s and I go
kitty is it go my god is she like from
the audience she goes oh my god you just
stand up whatever you know okay I did my
set and afterwards you know obviously we
get together in the lobby
and I go what do you do now and she goes
I work for Deepak Chopra so in my head
I'm like there's something there's a
connection
I'm not saying with the story babe I
thought of somebody for an impression go
ahead let me just do it and then she you
can do that thing you want to do it
first all right so the next day around
from the Comedy Store in La Jolla you've
been there right there's there used to
be the debug show for Chopra show operas
come on down to Deepa yeah and he had
like this this centre of self healing
uh-huh right here this office is there
and he had like a meditation room and
all the stuff there and she was just
meet me there during the day saying
whether he wasn't there but she had a
bunch of books with her yeah she could
just read these and that's how I got so
I was into it like and I read said I've
said this on this podcast I read seven
spiritual all success and I applaud them
in my life and then I got mad TV but I
really did like two or three months
they might not be connected but I
believe that is well he does a lot of
like Buddhist stuff right so I mean
there's legit stuff and what he's
teaching right but then what happened
was a couple years later my buddy goes
yeah he goes to my restaurant all the
time and he doesn't tip I was oh I
burned all the books that one thing that
one that says so much to me that I don't
believe him now
well he gets lamb basted by the science
community oh he does om harris actually
debated him and made him look very
foolish no really yeah it's online yes
so tell do a dive to tell her that
you've seen the documentary wild wild
country yes okay Oh show you should do
Oh show BA kua yes he doesn't blink at
all yeah and he just you know he calls
she like yeah oh Joe Rogan just saw that
the documentary he loves it yeah yeah I
love it I think that'd be great it's
weird - a lot of people still follow
dude on I like her hair
[Music]